hello everyone thank you for attending
so today I'm gonna be present and so I'm
gonna start again okay hello everyone
thank you for attending my name is
Ernest Lea Flores I'm an assistant
professor in the Pediatrics department
at the University of California San
Francisco so today I'm going to be
presenting a work that shows how we
successfully characterize leukemia from
the very early beginnings to having a
drug already in clinical trials so
hopefully this will give you an idea of
the type of studies that will help
identifying a therapeutic target and to
bring it all the way to like preclinical
and moving into the clinical part so the
title of my talk is identifying
vulnerabilities in hyper employee áall
to be exploited therapeutically
equivalent for blasting leukemia or ALM
is the most prevalent cancer in children
and adolescents it also accounts for the
highest mortality so in the five-year
rate a survival rate for children with
Ella has breaking grease so it's between
85 and 95 85 and 90 percent actually but
the remaining 15% is still accounting
for the highest mortality rate in this
leukemia type and it's due to particular
subtypes that has a very bad prognosis
mostly because they have a high risk of
relapse so among those we have high poly
fluid leukemia and that is the topic of
the presentation today and that's what
we've been focusing our efforts Peschel
II because being such a high risk
leukemia even if it accounts for only
two to four percent of the cases it
really urges for new therapeutics to be
found for these patients so happy
diploid b-cell leukemia is characterized
for
in less than 46 chromosomes as I
mentioned accounts for two to four
percent of Patrick ALM and he's divided
based on the karyotype meaning the
number of chromosomes so it could be
hi-hi polyploid 42 43 chromosomes we're
not going to be discussing that because
data has a similar prognosis that Tipler
leukemia but 32 to 39 chromosomes is
called low HEPA deployed and Kimia and
then they want to have like 25 to 30 one
chromosome is called near haploid they
never reached up like complete haploid Z
because I never lose chromosome 21 or
this X chromosome so these two subtypes
lo happy deploy a new haploid at the one
that I like the worst prognosis as
compared to non hyperlipidemias that was
described in Nats man eval in 2007 but
since things have been some other
publications and like stressing this
point and this year only had two
publications one by month near at all
from the Children's Oncology Group and
another one by king employee in at st.
Jude they have shown they like poor
outcomes of this leukemia and they have
urged for new therapeutic approaches
that could benefit this patient that do
not have any alternative treatments so
far so here it shows like a 30 bit
profile of hyper deployed patients we do
we start these working collaborations
that you are grouping some Jude led by
dr. mulligan to do the first large
characterization of high poly flow
leukemia so 124 patients were like
analyzed and the studies I'm going to be
providing here came from that genomic
characterization as well as they like
the rest of the omics Cretaceous
recession EE so here you can see the
chromosomes on the Left I like you see
the number that will represent the
chromosome and then each column
represents a patient so when we go to
law have deployed what we see
that all patients lose the same
chromosomes as you see all or most
patients with a logic deploy lose
chromosome two three four seven and so
on so the ones in blue the legend
indicates number of chromosomes so if
you see like kind of like white that
represent a diploid karyotype if it's
half of that we will be in blue if it's
double dutch instead of deeply becomes
tetraploid that you will see that in red
so you don't have a deep low you see out
of the blue like that represent the
number today chromosome numbers that get
lost and then what's interesting with
these patients is that they can redo
placate the chromosome number so if
let's say that they had like thirty two
chromosomes now they duplicate it and is
what's called mask low happy deployed so
the chromosome that was haploid meaning
just one of the two chromosomes
now it gets deployed so in a carrot i
would look normal
apparently normal but they want that
were like is still the two chromosomes
in the low happy deployed now they are
like duplicated so there are four so now
with tetraploid so what this makes is
that a patient a high like thirty two
chromosome now has 64 so that looks like
a hyper deployed leukemia but it's
important to make the distinction
between masks hypo deployed meaning that
they duplicated the chromosome content
versus a pure hyper diploid and the
reason is because the hyper diploid
patient's has a better prognosis than
hyper diploid so initially with patients
who are considered to be hyper diploid
and they were put in a standard
treatment but they have a very high rate
of relapse so when they were found that
some of the hybrid it could duplicate so
now is a clear distinction between those
two and one once a patient is seen to be
hyper diploid first thing that is done
is to see if they are like masked hyper
deployed or they are pure hydrogen load
so the same happens in the near haploid
as you seen the near happily
lose almost all chromosomes they might
preserve chromosome 14 chromosome 18 and
chromosome 21 as I said that II know I'd
like is never lost in this patience and
same for life in this X chromosomes so
in order to identify therapeutics that
could tackle these leukemias we need to
understand how the protein gets
deregulated but for that within a whole
omics characterization of this patient
leukemias to try to identify potential
targets the way we did that is first we
did a genomic characterization that was
published in 2013 in an age of genetic
paper that we give in collaboration with
some June first out arisen in the home
field and some of the patient was
subjected to whole genome sequence whole
exome sequence or target sequencing most
recently just Mulligan's group since
until did another characterization of a
larger number of leukemic patients that
was in the context of pax5 so it
included 2,000 patients with different
type of leukemias but it also included
80 high polyploid cases so between those
two studies we have a whole genomic
characterization of those patients we
also generate the transcriptomics data
either microarray RNA or RNA seek that
is a working process that we are
analyzing to try to find the gene
expression differences for these
leukemias and then we did a proteomics
characterization using protein profiling
that work we recently published this
here in cancer research and all three
work in combination to complement each
other to try to find these potential
vulnerabilities in this rukia so the
dynamic characterization of Hyperloop
really showed that law had to deploy a
new haploid are unique entities so these
addresses the question of is the patient
first losing some chromosome and the
cells becoming low happy
and then they lose more chromosomes and
they become near haploid or not
so these genomic characterization which
shows is that is not so as you see lo
hopper deployed like over 90% of those
leukemias has a mutation in p53 but yet
you don't find that in the near haploid
same for i KCF - who are the
transcription factors in over 50% of the
patients is not fun in near haploid and
vice versa in grass and I could see f3 a
finding a new helipad not in Doha per
deployed however despite having unique
signatures they effect kind of the same
like group of pathways so as you see
cell cycle 53 retinoblastoma and cdkn2a
MV are mutated you don't have the high
poly near haploid has also sneak into a
mb alterations so that would be an
retinal blastoma as well that would be
affecting cell cycle the brass pathway
is posed in late and in age like with
neurofibromatosis type 1 gene but also
in brass and lead 3 in the case of near
haploid also the epigenome li has like
some role to play in leukemia so as you
can see in this characterization so with
this information we try to see how can
we translate this into like potential
targets so then we decide to do a
biochemical analysis of these leukemias
and for that we use like a
characterization panel looking at pure
proteins or activated proteins as photo
proteins we use flow cytometry too for
that and the panel were generated using
commonly affected proteins in like
cancer is particularly in leukemia so
that includes the receptor tyrosine
kinase pathway PF kinase pathway razmik
kinase as well as protein synthesis
survival proteins
anti prefer
and apoptosis so before going to the
analysis I want to show you how we did a
protein characterization we use for flow
cytometry for that we implemented
protocol that had been developed by Gary
Nolan in Stanford so is basically taking
these cells fixing them which part
formaldehyde paralyzing with them with
methanol and then using antibodies to
detect either surface antigens that will
allow to look at sub population of cells
and then also yes yeah your connection
so ah there we go you're back on ok ok
so I'm gonna start with a should I start
with a slight of sugar when I slide back
I would say just start with this cuz it
seem like it started right when you
started talking again on slide 9 okay
perfect all right god just count to five
and then go ahead and start again thank
you mm-hmm so before going to the
analysis that we do these proteins I
want to show you how we characterize the
protein levels so we use a technology
first of flow using flow cytometry multi
parameter flow cytometry analysis of
extracellular and intracellular antigens
this protocol was developed by Gary
Nolan in Stanford and what it does is
you can fix the cells using perform
under hide and then paralyze them using
methanol so that allows to open pores
but keeping the integrity of the cells
so now we can use antibodies again with
surface antigens and that will allow to
distinguish between subpopulation of
cells and then have intracellular
antibodies that can recognize
intracellular projects simultaneously so
in this example here you have like now
would process by flow cytometry and in a
healthy cell there will be not that many
cells and many proteins
that get activated upon a stimulus so
that will be shown in green
so in unstimulated or basal conditions
you will have like some levels of a
particular protein or phosphoprotein
when it gets stimulated or the protein
that gets stimulated or phosphorylated
will be shown in green whereas in the
mutant they tend to up regulate those
protein so you have like more or you
have a higher intensity so that you can
detect it by like an increase in the
shift in fluorescence from this basil
and the baser might be already like
higher than the basil in the healthy
server so now we can transform that in a
heat map and then you can see how they
in case the basic conditions of the
wild-type and stimulation compared to
the basic conditions in the mutant and
the stimulation where yellow is
abbreviated and blue is down located so
now we can go and look at the
characterization that we did so here as
columns you see the different proteins
over 20 proteins from the different
pathways and then on the left every row
represent a patient so the first one is
the healthy control that we use and
whichever labels the healthy controls
half does consider zero and that's given
our value or like a color black any
labels above the zero the standard for
like the control will be shown in yellow
and that means have regulated anything
below that will show in blue down
regulated so as you see when we look at
the local PD patients you can see the 53
is elevated because it's mutant so it
cannot be degraded so it accumulates and
there is some proteins like beam that
will show also like high regulated
compared to near haploid and same for
busy lip cell but besides that all the
other proteins kind of show a similar
pattern post in low happily flow and
near
right so now we decide to see what
happens if we block or inactivate using
inhibitors any of these pathways so next
graph here we show so we use inhibitors
against receptor tyrosine kinase like
that cell kindness or jak-stat pathway
and the proliferation of the cells were
not diminished when we blow not kindness
surprisingly that's the light blue
surprisingly even effect preparation
either which we replicate with original
drugs part of that under later but it
didn't have any effect when we block pi3
kinase here you see two pi3 kinase
inhibitors in red and purple we have a
reduction in 50% proliferation of these
cells but striking when we block bcl-2
as shown here in orange we have a quick
decreasing preparation starting 10 nano
model so when we look at not just
preparation but induction of apoptosis
the ABT compound uploads PCL to was the
only one that also induce apoptosis so
that tell us that this cell to heilige
potential site toxic effect against
these leukemic cells so as I mention we
like replicate these experiments with
additional drugs we include more map
kinase here include - we do up to five
and we use up to 12 different pi3 kinase
inhibitors including isoforms specific
inhibitors for the different like
activated catalytic activity like
subtypes and we saw the same we saw like
a partial reduction of per iteration but
it was only with the AVT
and we used three different inhibitors
for apt apt 263 everything seven three
seven and a bt 199 and all three had
overlapping results increase in coverage
and when we compare and the increase in
proliferation even against chemotherapy
agents then we saw like a great increase
of caspase of active castes by Pacific
to inhibition that we didn't see with
any other job so we want to make sure
that we were not biased by just looking
at these drugs so then we do an unbiased
screen using a small library that
contains 94 compounds I think in
different targets and they that they are
like in different stages of APA approval
so and that result like which shows this
one represents 100% preparation and that
is shown with team so control and then
all these are like different like drugs
and chemotherapy and then if equals to
zero that would be a hundred percent
reduction so you see that abt 263 the
bcl-2 inhibitor was the only one that
like was the one that had the highest
efficacy the next one was gemcitabine
which is sub drive that has a very like
broad spectrum by doing happen
especially against high particularly
leukemia so then as a small molecule abt
263 was the highest-scoring one going
together with our results that I showed
previously so then we study the effect
of this drug in patient samples ex vivo
so we did have 24 hours using 100 micro
molar like and then we saw that all the
sorry 100 nanomolar all the patients
samples have a big decrease in
preparation and that resulted an
increase of apoptosis as shown here in
blue versus the untreated in red so all
these data although in vitro they were
very promising and encouraging the
result that were seen not showing here
by we did a comparison between 263 which
is a bcl-2 bcl-xl inhibitor with 7 3 7
as well and a bt 199 which is specific
for
is here too and what we saw is that all
three had overlapping effects so that
indicates that the inhibition is due to
bcl-2 so we decide to see how that we
have an effect in vivo
so we through patience ampuls so for low
HEPA deployed for near haploid and three
non high particular leukemias so each of
the patient sample had different
mutations profiles and they are wearing
grafted in six mice each once they reach
an engraftment cutoff level that was
either five ten to the seven with
imaging because these patients samples
were tagged with a luciferase recorder
or like five percent blasts presence in
pure blood so that was the cutoff to
start treatment so then they were
randomly assigned to either vehicle or
ABT so the those in that we use is after
the zero one they had like more than 15%
in prefer blood as I mentioned like they
were randomized and then we did at those
increased 25 min per kill 50 milli 75
mil per kill all for two days each up to
a hundred pratik to avoid tumor lysis
syndrome which have been described for
this drug and then after one week of
treatment they in the hundred meter cake
for the duration of the trial that was
60 days and every week we do imaging as
well as counting of peripheral blast in
glass in peripheral blood so here you
can see the monitoring that we do by
flow cytometry
we use a mouse cd45 to detect if the
blood is only mouse so you see like this
mouse not been engrafted but once they
in graph you see that city for a fact
they still have presence of the mouse
blood cells but when you start seeing in
the x-axis you still have human cd45
appearance so in this case goes all the
way to like 32 percent
of human leukemias already in demise so
here then I show like different patient
samples is just an example to show how
the treatment worked so that was a day
zero its patient sample healthy
permutation profile they were all
treated at the same time with the track
and then once like we analyzed at page
seven you'll see that it was completely
clear after treatment with ATT 199 for
all the leukemia in the mice and this I
have to say having at 24 hours already
so then after that we had like we stole
like a bay like rapid clearance from
both imaging as well as flow cytometry
so at the end of the trial
85% of demise was too low happily or
near haploid the have been treated with
a bt 199 survived the treatment whereas
those treated with vehicle died and the
control leukemias that were not
depending on be co2 and they didn't
respond to either vehicle or a bt 199
and as shown here so as i said like this
was you can find this work in cancer
research of march this year for
additional details so these data help
together with other like collaborating
work helped open the first clinical
trial for children with high risk low
Kimia for the treatment using a bt 199
either alone or in combination with
chemotherapy so in addition we wanted to
see what's the mechanism by why this
leukemia selectively response to a bt
199 also called phonetic plaques and
even could find biomarkers of drug
response so we found and this in
described for this drug already that in
order for like a cell to be sensitive to
this track he requires to have high
levels of bcl-2 since this is a
- my medic and as you see the control
leukemias that did not respond had lower
BC of two levels than low happy deployed
or even near haploid but what was
interesting is that we also saw that the
problem too big protein beam has very
high levels in some of the leukemias and
and in the ones that did not have high
levels of a beam they have high levels
of bad so what makes this leukemia so
sensitive is that they have high level
the pro survival but also high levels of
the product okay so when you use a drug
that blows the pro survival then you
have an odd number concentration of the
product at the proteins that will
drastically like kill the cells in a
very rapid way so that you tip the
balance in a way that the Leukemia the
gimmick cells now are very sensitive to
like death induced by the this drug so
to prove that beam and bad mediators of
that effect
we used CRISPR to eliminate beam in the
cells that contain high levels of beam
and as you see beam knock out one or
picnic outside completely eliminated
beam so in those cases that caspase
activation induced by the drug is
blunted completely blunted but if you
keep some of the I so far beam is still
happening so that is a cell line that
has a high level so beam on the left not
16 but big 1732 they don't have
endogenous levels of beam but they have
levels of pal and then when you like
used a drug then you also induce
apoptosis as you see here by cliff
caspase even faster than what you see in
the case of non sixteen here this
example was taken at 24 hours so bad
it's already like not down but we did
further analysis as you can see in the
paper where we did a short time courses
where Pam is still present and gets
induced
and that's when they paddies mediating
caspase by 24 hours doctors already
happened so many of the proteins already
been degraded the new which sees high
levels of caspase high levels
fifth part as indication of cells
already dying over like some of them
dead so but even in this case that they
don't have beam as I mentioned they're
like very sensitive to a bt 199 and I
was through the effective path so when
we use CRISPR analysis we know down by
and then you see that the activation of
caspase a bt 199 gives also blunted so
this shows how the drug works and what's
the like the effect on these leukemic
blast but we also observe is that
although it has a great efficacy in
clearing the blast from peripheral blood
here on the left is the control
leukemias there is no difference between
V equal in blue and a bt in yellow or
orange in the low happy deployed they at
the end of the 60-day trial only two
miles high like about 5% of blasts all
the others had zero levels and near
happy we could not detect any akima in
peripheral blood but when we look at the
liver the blasts were still resident
there so what it tells us is that these
might become a reservoir for blast and
when we stop the treatment leukemia may
come back because of the presence of the
Leukemia clothes are still in internal
organs so we decide to do a combination
therapy so here in the show in that in
the PS positive leukemia they don't have
levels of bcl-2 we use for these
pathology slides and because of that in
a bt 199 the same more or less didn't
respond but then you have a pioneer
haploid they have high
the Chema's that are positive for Brazil
- before treatment and also after
treatment or with vehicle and abt and
that's where like they are still lodging
there the clones so we need to find a
combination therapy that could be
synergistic with this drug in clearing
not only from peripheral blood and bone
marrow but also from internal organs so
for that study this is a word that we D
like we I have fellow men wrote whole
entire e did most of these studies and
we decided to do is use an unbiased
high-throughput drug screen to identify
effective drug combinations so for that
we used the hyper laser lines numb 16
dec 17 32 and mhh called 2 we use a like
close to 2,000 compounds bioactive
compounds including epigenetic compounds
and we look for decreased preparation as
using a cell tower glow assay as a
screening method so from the nineteen
hundred and fifty drugs that we use we
look at the 18 china had the highest
induction or highest inhibition of non
sixteen so once we identified that we
look at them and they basically belong
to like very few subgroups of classes of
drugs is lagging hitters proto some
inhibitors anti-military tubular agents
mostly chemotherapy and others including
one here Dyna sadly would sell like it
was considered to be a cell cycle
inhibitor so then we use these eighteen
drugs against the other two sir lines
and then with the different time course
24 48 72 hours in 96 hours and then from
those experiments we chose the top six
drugs then for those top six we did in
combination with also a BT
so the top six came to Dennis tightly
but with Excel
Casino star panobinostat onboard sesame
but from those the one that had the
highest combination or as reflected here
in the Bliss score column
it was Dyna cycling Dyna cycle has cell
cycle targets as well as some
transcription factors so when we combine
that exactly with a BT you can see here
zero concentration of both drugs we have
100% preparation but as we increase
already 16 nano molar of tennis I clip
an 8 nano molar of a BT reduces
proliferation by 80% and of course even
more drastically higher concentrations
and then when you look at the blister
score you see the concentration where
they these scores are higher just as
indicated here by blue
so all these studies and additional in
vitro studies that I'm showing here
Alton curves has to do a clinical trial
with this combination Dyna circuit and
AVG so this is like an example of a
mouse that was untreated will just be
given vehicle and then this Drive was 28
days replicating the course of
chemotherapy in patients so the images
are every 7 days see the chemo gets more
expanded more aggressive when we use a
BT we have a reduction by still be
present in like at 8:28 and that is
particularly because of the liver
questions when we use then exactly by
itself we didn't see much of an effect
though it produces but it's not like a
drastic reduction when we use in
combination abt Dyna socket he'll have
great singer synergy and there is no
gistic effect as you see here and we
could not find any blasts in any of the
tissues that we analyzed or by flow
cytometry or by any means that from the
different analysis that we did so this
is work in preparation for URI it
in preparation we expected to submit in
the next few weeks and then has
additional details on how this screen
howdy a in vitro studies ex-vivo as well
as the preclinical trial so I hope that
with this I have shown you how to take
leukemia forwards was very little known
before we started practicing it to give
it to categorize identify potential
targets from different avenues that all
converge and then how to do in vitro and
experiments to justify to in a
preclinical study and based on day very
like drastic and positive outcomes of
the treatment that we identify we're
able to have been into plants being
given out and a clinical trial for
pediatric cases of aln high-risk Ireland
and hopefully additional treatment we're
going to be able to be informing in this
way so as conclusions
so a biochemical characterization of
hyper leukemia is able to show a
probability levels of bcl-2 that
represent promising therapeutic targets
a pickling a study I showed that the use
of this track a bt 199 or Panetta clucks
dramatically reduced the leukemic burden
both in peripheral blood and not shown
here but also in bone marrow and it
extended the life of span of mice sinha
grafted with high poly flow era however
pathology analysis indicated that this
drug alone a single agent does not
eradicate the bikini clones from liver
and spleen and this is something that is
typical for mono therapy so because of
that is important to identify
combination therapies so four deities
first you need to have good try the
world's a small therapy but in
complement with additional ones
especially with a rationale so they are
synergistic
better than additive effects and this is
what we did here so the sensitivity to
abt one and nine is linked to the high
levels of bcl-2 but also low levels of
bcl-xl a high levels of beam amber and
OBT one and nine kindest apoptosis with
break efficacy in cells lacking beam as
we indicated and those cells are like
the ABT effect is merely bible so post
like demon bad as well as level so PCL
to now become biomarkers for drug
response in these cases and as we show
here the knockout Crispino part of both
beam or that were able to reduce the
levels of apoptosis induced by this drug
and that was a way of proving the does
the mechanism used by this track to
induce the cytotoxic effect so
additionally say like the combinatorial
effects like using an unbiased drugs
free into the define another drug that
like synergize with ABT was given us the
basis to do combination therapies and
then we did the pre connect preclinical
studies we're able to see the
synergistic effect in people so with all
these i just have to acknowledge all the
people involved in this work first in
our lab minion law is the division chief
and my great mentor has always helped me
like in my career as well as giving me
the opportunity to work starting working
with these patient samples when we
initially decide to characterize
leukemia people could be this work are
mentioned here some of them were my
technicians or like fellows that work
with me kaeleen
king Kyle Beckman giving you element
name Jennifer Osmond to the wing and was
recently Holly Perry
who gonna be like Smith paper very soon
hopefully in the Mulligan lab course dr.
Chas Mulligan and even como and intercom
horn felt to do the work on their side
Brown and was finishing jaraguá and the
nolan group Gary Nolan and car babies
for helping us with implementing the
multiply matrix optometry as well as to
do additional where the sight of that
was not including here so with that I
would like to thank you all for
attending I hope that you I could
understand in of what we do as well as
if you ideas on how to pursue a word to
have a therapeutic impact in the world
that you are doing with that I will say
goodbye until next time thank you
bye-bye
all right good job I was perfect in here
thank you thank you thank you for your
contribution just perfect oh there's
just that one part I will edit out but I
think I'll do not it looks to be about
40 minutes which is perfect that's great
that's great yeah yeah get this ready to
go for the cancer of it and then if you
have any questions don't hesitate to
reach out to me and you're able to
attend I would love to help you if not
posted on don't think yeah please give
us in this this great I didn't know
about lab rules before and I think like
and after I found out about we feel like
such a great great opportunity I mean
like the more we can express the world
in movie to like in an obligation of
scientific research
I think expanding that so it's not just
people who attend a particular meeting
but but you have it available online I
think a great idea so good
yeah we um I love the concept as well
and I think it's just a great great way
to get your content out to the world
those people that can't travel or afford
to travel and it's just a good mechanism
for that so thank you again thank you
for your contribution and well that's
not keep you posted
perfect all right Tracy have a great
rest of the day you too thank you
bye-bye
okay bye-bye